alors je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
on me critique sur mon niveau de dette
mais je dors beaucoup plus facilement
avec 50 milliards de dettes qu'avec les
premiers 50 mille francs français de
dettes que j'ai contractée quand j'ai
créé mon entreprise en 1991 pourquoi
parce que quand j'ai créé mon entreprise
j'avais un projet mais j'avais pas de
clients j'avais pas d'infrastructures
j'avais pas de collaborateurs et j'avais
pas un franc de chiffre d'affaires mais
un client insatisfait pour moi c'est un
client qui maquille me quitte un client
qui me quitter ben ça me fait mal au
coeur
et en plus qu'au coeur au portefeuille
mais d'abord au coeur parce que c'est
une question d'amour propre
donc moi quand je veux contractant un
emprunt je parle pas à ces gens là parce
qu ils sont des milliers je parle à des
intermédiaires
ces intermédiaires ce sont les banques
classiques que vous connaissez l'un de
mes principales banquiers intermédiaires
mais ce n'est qu'un intermédiaire c'est
la bnp par exemple donc la bnp dit ok
société altis je vais vous trouvez un
emprunt de 1 milliard de milliards dont
elle prend un mandat comme un agent
immobilier et va placer ce milliard sur
le marché auprès des gens dont j'ai
parlé à deux minutes ils sont ces fonds
gérés par des personnes physiques dont
beaucoup sont les français donc en fait
le monde de la finance est un beau monde
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
travaille alors dans chacun de nos pays
ma stratégie est simple c'est d'être
numéro 1 au numéro 2 et numéro 3 et 4 ça
me plaît pas beaucoup donc numéro 1 au
numéro deux un petit peu comme à l'école
1 donc en france on est numéro deux
après 25 ans de travail
ça va être difficile d'être numéro un
mais pourquoi pas par contre avaient
difficile de passer numéro 3 tut le
numéro 3 et 4 est très très loin non je
dis pourquoi ne pas investir aux etats
unis
alors vous allez aux états unis en
général on arrive à new york et donc je
me suis pas trop pris la tête j'ai
racheté le réseau de new york
j'ai été beaucoup critiqué cours de
bourse il était perturbé ça me laisse de
marbre
de la même manière que j'ai été beaucoup
critiqués quand j'ai commencé dans le
cap tous les copains je m étais fou tu
vas perdre ton argent comme j'en avais
pas bon il n'y a pas de grands risques
l'investissement que nous faisons aux
états unis c'est le plus gros
investissement jamais fait par un groupe
français aux états unis on a battu
sanofi d'accord moi j'arrive à new york
par exemple recruté quelqu'un ça prend
deux minutes
pas besoin de faire synchro 2000
déclaration
j'ai cinquante mille organise puisqu'ils
servent pas à grand chose en réalité ça
prend deux minutes et puis dans l'autre
sens ça prend deux minutes trente
et ça se passe très bien parce que la
personne comme il faut trois minutes
pour retrouver un nouveau travail pdt
puisqu'il faut deux minutes pour
discuter et une minute pour le trouver
tout ça ça marche bien donc on est
entouré de gens qui sont beaucoup plus
sains que nous nous on est sans doute
beaucoup plus d'intelligence mais
l'intelligence nuit aux sports nuit à la
rapidité
elle mettait un chercheur fou pour
avancer vite ne vais pas y arriver
bon l'entrepreneur c'est le gars qui
veut avancer vite pas lentement